hello everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show outside the
studio with director producer Linda
goldstein Milton of the doc somewhere
between we wanted to ask Linda what was
it like being ultimately in charge of
everything that went well and could
possibly go wrong on your film
understood that you've produced before
and been a co-director but this was your
first real time sort of steering the
ship so to speak yeah this was the first
time without the net so it was it was
exciting it was scary I had really
fantastic teachers i have i've been
producing films for a long time so there
are certain aspects of it that felt
comfortable but you know I want to learn
from every experience in every
experience is different so I want to use
every every film as a learning
opportunity but the the first
documentary that I co-directed with
Lynda Hawkins Costigan in the world
according to Sesame Street she came from
the documentary world and she was such a
generous teacher and we were we were
great partnership and that was really
wonderful and we and also our editor for
the role according to Sesame Street k
anand who's cut every extraordinary
documentary ever into the films that
she's cut won Academy Awards and so
field lucky enough to call her a friend
and a mentor so I feel like I got all of
this great teaching and then it was I
had to they had to send me out the door
to do myself so I felt like I had a
really good foundation and then I was
also working with my my film family my
my film husband's my work husbands and
so together this is the second film we
worked on together so there was a very
comfortable shorthand that that worked
really really well but knowing that you
know it lives and dies on my ideas in my
direction you know it's daunting
sometimes it was daunting but also
exhilarating and knowing that it was a
very personal film after we finished the
world according to Sesame Street I had
the idea for this film
Linda had an idea for also a personal
film to do and we we both kind of had
the conversation with each other honey I
have something to talk to you about
because we did have this amazing
experience and we'll make films together
again but because it was personal it
just made sense that we kind of had to
go off and do our own personal films but
she you know she looked at rough cuts
she gave me really valuable note so I
feel like there was you know there was
there I got such great support from all
different people from my husband who you
know has been a filmmaker for a long
time and for my friends and my family
and a lot of them are filmmakers so
never really felt alone except maybe
three o'clock in the morning when I
stressing out about something but I can
really stop to think that I am making
this film in collaboration with people
and that's something that I really love
about filmmaking that it's a
collaborative art so when I would when I
would get really nervous and stressed
out I knew that there was I stopped for
a minute I could ask somebody for help
mm-hmm and that's got to be to knowing
that it was a collaboration and probably
that fuel that it was a personal story
because I think too when it's your first
time sort of having that sense of
ownership and people can sense that they
sort of it's hard not to waver how do
you kind of still at the end of the day
say well I'm calling the shots without
being you know the dreaded B word but
still kind of able to be firm and
friendly but know that ultimately it's
your project and what you say goes all
right I'm gonna navigate that well
because because it starts as the
collaboration to be a really important
part of that is listening so I can put
my ideas on the table in terms of story
in terms of character in terms of camera
and I am NOT the most technically adept
person so with every film we have these
tech summits is look at these big
massive conference calls trying to
figure out because every time we've made
a film dude with a new camera or
system that's come out so I want to
empower my cinematographers to you know
use cutting-edge technology but what are
the what are going to be the limitations
what are the you know in terms of
visuals but in terms of cost and really
weighing all of the options so for me
it's really about posing I posing the
questions listening gathering
information and really listening to
people and ultimately I think the reason
why my team and I have worked so well
together for so long is that they feel
heard they know that I'm just not
arbitrarily making a decision because
I'm the judge you know and and a lot of
times they get their way and then
sometimes it's like I hear ya and you
know what I want to do that so and I
think that that really comes with us
working together over several films
together but it's about it's about
listening to people and you know what i
want to make the best film that i can
and i didn't go to film school and i'm
very aware of my own limitations as a
filmmaker so I'm constantly looking for
input and I think that's that people
appreciate that in terms of that I'm
gathering this information so then when
I finally do make a decision they're
respectful of it